[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci Claude prendre le temps avec nous
en pleine répétition pour un projet que
tu portes pourquoi il est important pour
toi de mener ce projet pour moi ce
projet FACA
ça c'est un grand projet parce que c'est
le début de tout et c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai invité
on va dire mes potes mes proches pour
commencer la voiture avec moi un début
donc FACA ça veut dire ça je plante
la racine ici à la Réunion surtout parce
que maintenant je suis installé ici à la
Réunion et aussi de la racine parce que
j'ai envie de rassembler aussi des gens
et après de on va dire de se ramifier un
peu partout dans le monde plus tard mais
oui c'est c'est fait car c'est la racine
comment tu décrirais la musique que tu
fais je fais de la musique
traditionnelle
d'ici de la Réunion et de Madagascar
parce que j'utilise aussi des
instruments d'ici mais quand même je
suis influencé par tout ce que j'entends
aussi et c'était naturel pour moi de ne
pas quitter mes racines
et juste d'habiller ma musique pas ce
que j'écoute et ce que je vois aussi
[Musique]
de quoi il est important pour toi de
parler dans dans tes textes dans mes
textes c'est je raconte tout ce que je
vois tout ce qui me touche ça peut être
politique ça peut être aussi la fête
parce que j'aime la fête ça peut ça peut
parler aussi de la jeunesse au fait oui
c'est hyper
et je trouve c'est important de quand
même se rattacher à l'histoire et c'est
l'histoire maintenant c'est parce qu'on
va écrire aussi l'histoire donc tout ce
qu'on a
entendu parce qu'on n'a pas vécu aussi
l'histoire comment maintenant nous on
écrit aussi notre histoire en se basant
sur ce qu'on
nos ancêtres et nous on a vécu avant et
nous c'est maintenant qu'on écrit aussi
l'histoire donc j'ai envie de montrer ça
aux jeunes que ça y est les gars let's
go c'est à nous comment tu es arrivé à
la musique mais la première fois où tu
as joué de la musique comment ça s'est
passé je suis rentré en studio
d'enregistrement la première fois quand
j'avais 15 ans et c'était entre potes
entre potes on se dit bon allez on va
faire du hip-hop du rap donc j'ai écrit
à 15 ans
un texte et voilà j'ai commencé comme ça
à entrer en studio et jamais arrêté de
plus au fait
[Musique]
des danseurs aujourd'hui tu te consacres
beaucoup plus à la musique qu'est-ce qui
pousse à cette bascule
laissez un peu en pause la danse pour se
consacrer à la musique s'il y a pas de
frontière si tu as envie de bouger
danser tu danses si tu as envie de
chanter tu chantes et donc là je me
considère pas comme chanteur ou danseur
je fais de l'art et j'essaye de
m'épanouir dedans est-ce qu'il y a une
motivation particulière qui te pousse à
monter ce projet à avancer dans ta
carrière d'artiste moi j'ai grandi dans
le mua le milieu artistique depuis tout
petit et je sais faire que ça
si j'ai décidé de faire ça aussi c'est
parce que c'est c'est j'aime la liberté
qu'on adore donc j'aime créer et
à partir du moment où j'ai mon cerveau
qui
qui fait des propositions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]